police Source beware of Eastern Parkway
this chabus I hope I'm pronouncing
correctly you got it you nailed it uh it
says a pro Palestinian protest has been
planned for this chabas afternoon near
the Crown Heights neighborhood this is
um yikes this is from this is from today
and they say the flood Brooklyn for Gaza
protest is scheduled 3 p.m. this shabas
at the Brooklyn Museum in Crown Heights
and is expected to draw large crowds in
support of Palestinians and Gaza quote
Jews should definitely avoid the area a
police source told Co live there's no
Intel at this time in which direction
the protest will head locals should
definitely stay away from Eastern
Parkway in that area now the question of
course is it's hard for Jews to avoid
Crown Heights well sure but the question
is is this like what's the source you
know I mean no disrespect to se if I'm
not familiar with them should we believe
this let me tell you this right now if
there is going to be a leftist pro
Palestine March and you are Jewish you I
I would I would tell you uh uh and it it
sucks to say but you are in danger from
these people I think so too no question
so this is Crown Heights Crown Heights
is where the laich
um um the booklyn museum is basically in
Crown Heights and there were riots in
Crown Heights that's where the Crown
Heights riots took place during the
dinkin
administration um he told the police to
stand down Eric Adams won't tell the
police to stand down he can't
really it's not on well he ran on a I'm
going to get tough on crime ticket yes
and he's also been he's also come out
very strongly in a way that bill
DeBlasio certainly basio doesn't know
what strong
means he certainly doesn't
know you know a lot of things that bill
doesn't know right for but Adams has
been has been good uh and he is a former
cop um but it is a this is a gigantic
strain as we were actually we were
talking about this before we started um
this is a strain on the Democratic
Coalition but in New York of all places
um there's going to be a very high see
the thing about
laim is they they don't back down um
they're the only Jews left in Crown
Heights which in the 50s as late as the
50s and 60s was a very
significant Jewish neighborhood that had
many different kinds of Jews in it every
other Jewish Community for all practical
purposes left Crown Heights when as they
used to say the neighborhood changed uh
but the the the the grand rabbi vavich
the re the
rebi uh Rabbi
schneerson um of said we don't we're not
going to run we're we're this is our
neighborhood and we're staying here uh
these are these are tough guys they're
you
know the problem is they're a
minority Jews are not actually
particularly handy in the United States
with um
self-defense but on the other hand a lot
of lessons have been learned the idea
the the idea that the New York City
Police would permit an encounter between
the you know uh kidum of
laich and this protest um is insane they
we don't know which direction they're
going to go in you got to make sure you
know what direction they go in and you
got to make sure it doesn't go in the
direction you think there'll be violence
in Crown Heights
I really don't think so but but then
again a lot of things have happened that
I never thought would happen yeah uh we
have this tweet from Nikki freed she's
of course a Democrat running uh for
governor in Florida chairwoman of the
Florida Dems she responded to a video we
just talked about in a previous segment
Jewish students at Cooper Union College
have been locked inside the library for
their own safety as a mob of
anti-israeli protesters block the doors
she said this is outage those are not
Israeli
students right she said this is
outrageous and we are seeing these types
of videos and stories all over our
country we live in a civil society where
this is not only not okay but illegal
and everyone has a responsibility to
stand up against hate speech let me also
be very clear anti-israel is
anti-Semitism the Democrats are going to
be ripped to shreds this election cycle
over this issue really you really think
so absolutely Nikki freed is trying to
win over Democrat votes in Florida and
she's coming out in defense of Israel
good
luck now a lot of a lot of prominent
liberals have have begun to push back on
the left we had uh and people in pop
culture how look at the Harvard students
who came out there was there was at
Blacklist against them because they're
they're they're Pro Hamas and and it was
not just Pro Palestine it was them
calling the Hamas the resistance
fighting back I mean this is crazy stuff
if you're a Democrat and you need that
10 to 20% of progressive left vote and
you are pro-israel you've lost it no
question question these people are
fervently anti-israel there were also
3,000 UK artists who signed a letter
that was basically Pro Palestinian pro-
ceasefire anti-israel it's so we were
talking about this yesterday the amount
of celebrities I've watched come out in
try to find Middle Ground only to be
torn to shreds on both sides has been
truly incredible to watch as what 3,000
of them signed the letter to Biden two
days ago that said that the Hollywood
people so a lot of those people who are
like leftists uh or at the very least
they vote Democrat all the time right
and they're realizing now just how
fractured aspects of the party that
they've supported for all these years
actually are because they're seeing
something they've never seen before it's
like I said earlier I will never be more
amazed at the idea of the people who'
have been calling people Nazis for four
years breaking down and doing this it's
absolutely insane but I just don't think
that a lot of the the celebrities who
maybe they they vote Democrat but they
don't pay super close attention to
politics other than orange man bad right
they don't really look at it that
closely maybe they follow their local
governor's race or something like that
but they didn't realize if you're not
super politically aware if you're not
following what's going on in the news
you wouldn't know this was happening
it's kind of the same way when we were
talking a while ago about what was
happening in England a couple years ago
when uh the the Muslim population was
protesting lgbtq stuff within the school
districts that was so fascinating right
so it goes a lot to that same they don't
realize that there is fracture within
their audience because they it's a weird
type of cognitive happen that's that's
been happening in Canada too I think
it's because they don't pay attention so
uh we have we have this idea it's a
really good idea it's a game show U I
think we should do it so maybe we just
need to get someone who's going to start
setting it up it's a trivia political
trivia game show where we get left
versus right and we ask basic topical
news questions and then we see who gets
the most correct cor answers maybe a
little history maybe a little modern
history no of course for sure like who
built the the Berlin Wall this would be
this would be interesting because like
what would happen is I think both sides
would I'm I'm correct and they would
cite their new source which would be CNN
and then somebody else would cite
another source or they would just
sighting sources is it doesn't matter
the question uh that I like to cite is
what was the name of the Ukrainian
prosecutor fired after Joe Biden
threatened to withhold $1 billion in
loan guarantees of course the left is
going to say huh and the right's going
to go Victor
shoken and it's like well another
thousand points for or the left will
just say that didn't happen and you'll
like actually it did happen you'll have
to explain it all no you're wrong you're
wrong so so the lefties won't come on
your show because they will not they
will not be confronted with facts they
were they you know how many times I've
tried to get people from the left on on
my show of course but my point the point
I want to make going back you know
outside of the the game show question is
T strong voice actress very well-known
like one of the most famous voice act
actresses of Our Generation Harley Quinn
Batgirl Timmy Turner you name it uh she
was very woke and very left despite the
fact the left has been saying for a
decade plus I mean for a long time that
they want to end Israel Patrice Ker's
2015 black lives matter saying end the
imperialist project that is known as
Israel and and and she didn't care she
didn't care when people like or you or
any of us said calmly hey like this is
not this is not good you shouldn't
support these groups no she blocks you
she says screw you I'm I'm going to stay
in my lane and and keep getting my
paychecks until they attacked until
Hamas massacred a bunch of civilians and
that's part of their Doctrine to kill
civilians and capture them for as
bargaining chips and when she got mad
and tweeted this is an outrage they
fired her yep they fired her from her
job really didn't even tell her didn't
even tell her she found out on social
media just tweeted she's no longer going
to be voicing this character on our show
with without without like seriously you
got a problem with someone sweet you
talk you call them on the phone first
nope and she was shocked she was so
shocked by this and you know that's like
what happened to Gina corano yeah but
Gina corano did nothing wrong right like
ter but Tara CHS to side with people who
are evil and have for a decade been
longer than this but prominently calling
for an end to Israel and she ignored
that because at the time what she was
protesting or what she was virtue
signaling about had nothing to do with
so it didn't matter at that time if it's
BLM they're worried in 2020 about what's
going on with black lives matter and
George Floyd but it's just that the
chickens had not come home to roost yet
cuz now we're here you know there's a
famous poem that's kind of about when
you don't speak up for other people and
what eventually happens to you but I'll
tell you something wait Amy Schumer
wrote that
right well speaking of
Schumer that was exactly the point I was
going to make you know frankly there is
no group in America that is more
responsible for this state of affairs
than the
Jews the Chuck Schumer of the world the
liberal donors who have been screaming
about how the the ADLs of the world what
we have to worry about is white
supremacist white nationalism ignoring
what was seething and bubbling and as
Tim said all you had to do was pay
attention they refused to do that
because they're on a team and their team
they replaced the faith of their
ancestors with the the faith of FDR
interesting and the American the the the
Church of the American assimilated Jew
is the Democratic party and Democrat and
Jewish institutions that have been so
profoundly influential
because of the ability of Jews to
succeed in so many areas of
endeavor all the things that you're that
these lunatics in your live chat are
going on about the disproportional this
yes it is true that Jews are
disproportionately represented in areas
requiring incredibly hard work high
intelligence and diligence uh
surprisingly to people who are
unfamiliar with those Concepts but not
surprisingly to the rest of
us
Jews have been in a position to stop it
from happening and they have not only
let it happen they have enabled it
someone like Chuck
Schumer nothing is more important to him
than maintaining his personal position
of power and privilege in the United
States Senate so that he let the Iran
deal go through he was given permission
to meekly wave his hand about
if that if if Schumer had not wanted it
to go through it would not have gone
through you mean the $6 billion no I'm
talking about the original Obama deal
going back APAC like the entire ex
purpose of the existence of APAC is to
prevent things like the Iran deal they
did not prevent it because they didn't
want to rock the boat with the
Democratic party have Jews woken up
probably not never feels like they ever
never feels like they ever group I just
want to mention to people uh we have
been absolutely paying attention to the
uh uh what's going on in Maine oh the
shooting there yeah but there it's like
I just want to let you guys know there
there are multiple scenes some people
are concerned it may be a terar attack
two active Shooters in different
locations some reporting up to 16 have
been shot but we we don't know anything
right now other than that's that's all I
can say I mean there's nothing else to
be said right if if you're in the area
in uh was it Leon Le yeah uh lock your
doors and stay inside is what the police
are saying I guess when it comes to
Maine you don't have to worry about any
Jews or even Arabs being involved I
don't think that's true I don't think
that's true I don't think that's true
anywhere in the country I I I I I don't
want to say too much but I believe there
is a potentiality that this is related
to Israel Palestine could be there's
also I mean there's been a lot of
illegal immigration across the Canadian
border oddly um New Hampshire just put
together a coalition or something to try
and deal with illegal immigration coming
from the north uh so there has been
there has been a lot of that also you
see with the immigration situation
you've seen the bid Administration
literally flying people all over the
country to disseminate the 7 million
people that they want to come into this
country for some crazy reason uh in as
many different places as possible but to
what you were saying earlier like why
why they vote for something why they
vote for the Democrat Party Democratic
party when you feel like it may be going
against interest but it's also like
think about what they do in Chicago they
they they get rid of one guy and they
vote in another guy who's going to
implement policies just as bad high
crime areas don't vote in like I feel
like gone of the days and maybe I'm just
young so I don't understand but like I
don't see New York go ever going back to
somebody like Giuliani right you know
what I'm saying like I don't feel like
any of these bigger at least the cities
the big cities that have large uh like a
large condensed group of people I don't
feel like they learn their lessons well
the middle class has left these cities
you can only to live in New York City
you have to either be very wealthy I
left in January after like 20 something
years you were I remember hearing I said
in January that was the last middle
class person and that was you that was
me yeah thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net
time